[Music]
in
only in china news oh [ __ ]
submitted by bling bling every time i
come over here
chinese tv is being criticized for
blurring in blurring the earrings on
male actors why are they blurring the
earrings because it leads to political
dissent
[ __ ] tracking men only to blur the
[ __ ] earring that is
that guy who's editing that video must
be pissed for me it's so funny that like
what is so
provocative or appalling about
earrings on the ear that makes them go
we have to censor this
it's gang-related button yeah
gang-related so there are at least
two shows on this chinese video
streaming site called no earrings
that have blurred the earrings that's
way more noticeable
that's ten thousand times more
noticeable so it's blurring and also
digital what about blurring his feminine
face
i know dude you know what the [ __ ] i was
thinking but i'm so glad you said i'm
like
how are we supposed to know if this
person's a woman or not why don't we
blur his [ __ ] lipstick dude
he's got some great lipsticks chinese
pop stars try to be like korean pop
stars
but they're like the bootleg version
just like their products
so here's another one i think they're
just blurring out the earrings because
it's so obscenely huge
those are large earrings they are huge
it covers half his neck i'm offended
but they're also digitally altering the
earlobes like this that looks big as
[ __ ]
she's wearing earrings here who look
like a monkey that is so
dumb he's the monkey king dude okay why
why do they gotta do no this is what he
usually looks like he's not conservative
yeah
i guess that'll teach you if my ears
start if my earlobes started looking
screwed up on tv i'd be like well i
guess no more earrings did you guys ever
get earrings
i had five piercings i grew up in a com
very conservative household i guess and
they thought that it was like
pretty bad so this platform denied that
china's
strict sensors had ordered the blurring
of earrings
do you think it was like uh the studio's
call like oh no we have to do this man
we're gonna get so many complaints
maybe so many people gonna call in today
yeah because remember how recently they
they're doing the censorship um of
banning depictions of hip-hop
and actors with tattoos
like a chinese house mom just watching
tv she was like oh my god is that a
[ __ ] earring [ __ ] [ __ ]
hello yeah ccctv it's actually
s-a-f-p-r-f-t
you were collecting stuff china china
china china china tv
i think i see a [ __ ] earring man what
kind of [ __ ] is that
because you're a [ __ ] earring the
state administration of press
publication radio film and television
what kind of [ __ ] show are you
running man my children is watching this
and you gotta have a [ __ ] earring on
a man
they're so [ __ ] there's so many
problems going on in china but the thing
they're focusing on is the earrings
here yeah never mind the lead in the
fish that they're [ __ ] selling to
people and the baby products that's all
[ __ ] up you know the
sewage water the sewage oil that you're
cooking tonight never mind that dude
we can't have them wear earrings have
you seen that [ __ ] yes sewage oil we
don't know
yeah they make money no they make money
like a lady bought a house with that
[ __ ] dude
what is that so not okay gutter oil is
what it's called gutter oil
so yeah like so a lot of restaurants
taste like butter there's like a lot of
people that
they they're cooking oils in the sink
and all that stuff so
their old sewage system and pipes they
clog up
but what you know what these ladies are
doing is they [ __ ] go and open up the
manhole and then they
just open like just they scoop skim it
off the top yeah skim up the
gutter oil and then they just go back
and use it to refry foods and all that
stuff
i'm not about that get to restaurants
and street vendors orange chicken is
actually batterless
the oil and it just kind of crumbles and
wrinkles up in front i heard it makes
food taste good but i do do
it's a through baby straight up dude
exactly yeah i don't want dude oil on my
food
i did that brick of fat was floating in
cocka yeah that's the problem and then
it's like even though you reheat it
i don't know this probably has the
essence of cocker on the reheated and
distill it like multiple times over for
me to be like
maybe that's where the flavor come from
the doo-doo
barther quanjiman there's no way you eat
i'm assuming that's your full name
all right that's a mule in lines again
we're like
i ate street food in mainly in china
it was delicious you ain't gutter oil no
i ate street food in mainland china i
don't i mean it was probably
toxic in some way but it was delicious
like i just didn't think about it maybe
before you went to china you were just
normal
like level-headed really yeah i know
that it [ __ ] me up
now this is what the result is i get
scared to eat food outside of the
country now
but did you die i didn't but then my
[ __ ] butthole did
oh like i get scared sometimes like now
i'm scared because like i just don't eat
like a lot of fried food anymore and all
this [ __ ]
like in asia a lot of the food is
[ __ ] fried specifically the street
food
so now i feel like if i go back i'm just
gonna be yakking all over the place man
sometimes it's just the the traveler's
gut right the bacteria
like we're not used to yeah so it's not
bad food it's just
we don't have the probiotic or whatever
it is so we eat their local food and
even if it is clean and everything's
done right we get we get uh upset
stomachs that's why i usually just lick
the stop sign that's like the first
thing i do when i get it
get off the plane and you're like
where's the [ __ ] stop sign
no i have a general rule i just don't
eat spicy like spicy food when i travel
what if you go to a spicy regular spicy
food here [ __ ] me oh like the bacterial
[ __ ] over there that
i'm not used to and including spicy food
i'm [ __ ] fire [ __ ]
yeah i just have leaky ass all over the
place and it kills the bacteria
huh i love street food though and you
eat it too
delicious hot and not spicy a hole in
the wall restaurant is like the best
place like
if it's like under a train station
you're like great that's absolutely what
i want in my body right now yeah
some of those places are really nice
they really are yeah yeah they look like
little malls
exactly they're like 70 of our [ __ ]
[ __ ] like if you get a good one they're
dope like even like sure tacos right
like i've been to arguably pop it like
40 or 50 of them in this [ __ ] city
thanks for taking us yeah but 80 percent
of them were [ __ ] trash dude
take me to the other ones like it's just
very basic some of them got me sick so
you know because we're like hunting for
new taco spots yeah you just got to take
that risk sometimes
because sometimes you're looking at a
spot and there's not a lot of people
there and you're like that might be
the hidden gem but then you look at the
mexican people around you and they're
going like this
there's a reason why is the guy changing
a tire
don't do it you're gonna regret it
there's a general truth that i found out
for taco joints in l.a
if there's no people there there's a
reason for it that's what we say about
chinese restaurants
people have tried it there and it's not
because people don't know about it
people try it they don't like it so if
you go to the spots where there's people
are where it's popping
is for sure gonna be bomb as well and
what's popping like five people no like
a [ __ ] like absolutely
like real popular that's what it's
called the place you took us to oh yeah
tacos
that one that was good there's another
place called tacos e tire shop
[ __ ] compton is [ __ ] delicious and
i think there's another one
another branch that they're opening up
in pasadena now like a truck oh [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] delicious there's like
seven taco spots i love in l.a can you
take this
yeah el chato on olympic that's like
well they've got a big line so are you
doubling back on what you say yeah
el chato's like it's like this just
because there's a lot of spots now like
for example if i get asada
everybody likes that [ __ ] when they cook
it with charcoal and there's not that
many places that do it that's true why
why don't they why they are there's
three or four oh
the taco spots here in la i say are
better than alcohol in all your taco
adventures have you gone any to any
places that have tacos
what's that steamed tacos no steam tacos
oh good
i've never had like they steamed the
tortilla yeah so they like make a taco
and then they put like they steam it and
to cook it
that sounds delicious i've only had it
while i had it so i don't know if they
have it
i don't know i've never had that that
sounds so maybe you should open one
maybe you guys should open one i don't
know nothing about it the korean guy
though
do i like roy choi to you i don't know
who that is i love roy choi shout out to
rochoy get your abuela's
recipe and then make it no she doesn't
make them
you can open up next to sip and call it
munch yeah
munch and sip oh yeah that's for free
you can take that for free
i'm gonna should have you the as our
marketing director
oh i'd love that but boze will be pissed
she just went into marketing yellow buds
i know
have bows do it i'll do y'alls voices
that's fine that's perfect dude anyway
we were talking about china
oh yeah oh blurring yeah blurring out
the earrings like 45 yeah so there were
people commenting
uh so one commented this is gender
stereotyping another
asked if a woman with short hair would
have to blur her whole head
duh and then another one oh is it a
gender thing they're like oh guys
shouldn't wear earrings or what is it
well that's how people are taking it
oh and then this other one uh said how
about banning all those female stars who
look genderless
what's interesting in china i feel like
the quote-unquote netizens can complain
as much as they want nothing's going to
change
like you could do it as much as you want
what the [ __ ] are you going to do like
the government's not going to change for
you never has
so they're just going to get angry and
then nothing's going to happen do you
think it's more about like
cultural invasion too like you were
saying it's like the south korean pop
stars like as
korean pop gets more and more popular um
and that kind of fashion makes its way
into china like is that like a symbol
of the fashion that they're trying to
blur so they're saying it's like men
wearing earrings yes it is gender but
like that is a south korean thing
men wearing an earring like that might
be holding hands and [ __ ] [ __ ] so i
don't know korea is a very interesting
space
they have like an interesting level of
affection that i guess like western
people don't see as normal for
heterosexual males
because i've seen dudes like [ __ ]
hold hands and [ __ ] i want to say [ __ ]
yeah they you know sometimes when they
don't be weird we're just bros yeah
two men celebrating each other's
strengths it's very affectionate yeah
they just take a shot of soju out of
their [ __ ] and they [ __ ] drink
that [ __ ] they actually lift the guy up
and they go like this
put him down because he's still koreans
are so strong yeah oh bend over
okay yeah now we're brothers
[Laughter]
one thing that's funny is when i see
them at the
spa and scrubbing each other oh yeah the
shit's tight like
is it funny because they're just going
at it hard i don't know it's almost like
[ __ ] no it's it's almost like a dad
taking care of a son but they're the
same
age oh that's quite cute it's cute it's
funny
but also sometimes it looks like one's
the servant and one's the king
yeah yeah it's just an interesting
relationship forget my ball sack
yes
[Music]
um